[Music]  yes  it's back it's flutie 2d friday remember  at the beginning of the pandemic we  played some songs to try to lift  people's spirits well here we are at the  holidays now week or so ago we were  talking about a song  for the holidays that's got my name  written all over it i bet you can figure  it out  [Music]  hey  [Music]  [Applause]  there it is it's my own national anthem  so if i had three hands i put my hand  over my heart  yay nate thank you it's so fun to play  the flute sherry  as you know i've been playing the flute  since i was in the fifth grade  and i think it now is an appropriate  time obviously with the pandemic is  still on and we need our spirits lifted  back in the day my family and i would  actually wander around our neighborhood  and do christmas carols we may try that  this weekend  oh you should name that's very cool